this is the last Mabel corn I will share
with you all of my knowledge uh I want
to go voice that that was that was
amazing yeah that was really funny
tell me um this is an episode where they
need to figure out a way to block their
minds from bill cipher so they say that
they apparently need a unicorn hair and
it can only be found by someone with the
pure of heart pure so Mabel takes on the
challenge and is not so purified I don't
like your sprays together
oh my girlfriends together they go they
find this place in an hour so pretty
quick
and this dick of a unicorn just keeps
jerking or one thing we've learned
unicorns are bitches excuse me I have to
go pose in front of a rainbow and very
creepy looking that one I love the big
eyes and everything I'm like it was so
funny but it was so creepy
the winning the Rosa the mighty why yeah
those oh the whinnying yeah praise rot
yeah
oh yeah why much travel too but in this
economy Oh
so Mabel tries to do all this stuff cuz
apparently she's not pure of heart but
it turns out they were just or this one
at least was just sticking around with
her and it's like oh we can't tell we
just point our horns and direction of
rainbows and play rave music uh and so
they just had this great big fight
that's totally off-screen and they
apparently Massacre quite a few unicorns
are my good unicorn tears can kill
plants yes and they also get a bunch of
treasure which Stan steals I gave us all
this treasure just to get rid of us and
while that's going on we also have a
back story about dippers other uncle
about Ford cipher
bill cipher is kind back and we find out
that cypher possessed his mind before
and tricked him into building the
Stargate and that the dimensions need to
fuse because that's the way ciphers just
gonna annihilate the world pretty much
apparently he just comes from the quote
unquote Nightmare Realm like that gets
like event horizon there's no way a
source oh yeah and he wants to take it
over and so they finally get the unicorn
hair and they have to separate you know
they're now they're in this film where
they can't get to him so cypher is not
looking for someone to possess in order
to get into that realm my guess is it's
gonna be Gideon ah but it could be
everybody it's me I don't actually know
you know what maybe not because that was
just from a storytelling perspective
well that'd be a bigger twist if it was
just somebody you didn't think like if
it was a Wendy or one of the girlfriends
or something like that that just said we
got Italy aha
it's me feel safer it's like would that
be a pretty big twist so maybe it will
be Flo Gideon me Gideon will work its
way in some other way cuz obviously they
were talking about him working his way
and somehow uh so yeah this was a lot of
fun of course like the ponies and stuff
are really big right now uh and even
though I don't it doesn't feel like a
say at time necessarily that just her
seems like all a tease girls they like
it even kind of now stuff I don't know
is that I guess you know of course will
never not be I've always called the last
Mabel corn so I'm assuming that yeah ask
unicorn uh I think just sort of the
unicorn mystery and elegans and
prettiness SS like a rainbow bright
crust with my little pony
yeah it was like kind of
all-encompassing like kind of the old
school girl show yeah I was gonna say I
don't even know if like oh they were all
that messed up I would have watched oh
but if there was uh yeah I know a
terrible person yeah I don't know if
that's really like shows now it probably
is more like the ADI because they
usually do ad shows back then anyway
surprised more yeah like probably big
emphasis on the last unicorn or
something it was kind of draw I'm like a
creepy version of The Last Unicorn uh
but uh then
Accor was creepy as fuck all areas as
well uh was I the only one who when
watching them about to do that great big
fight and then it cut away it was one of
the few times I was like you know I
actually don't need to know the mystery
this time can I see if I want it isn't
that so bad
you know it's like I just want you see
some unicorns get their asses handed to
them it's funny imagining what's going
on while they're talking cuz you're in
that scene with bill cipher for a while
you're in that scene for a while so just
imagining that fight is still going on
is kind of funny oh just a my hair kid
yeah like that like that I might still
be going on while they're talking about
this uh so I love Mable's the whole
thing at the end just you know the moral
of the story is you know see Mabel
you're a good person it's okay I learned
that moralities relative Mondego what
the hell was Stan's playing with the
bugs oh my god fucking some puppies I
just burst out laughing that was right
up there when like Moe Szyslak like ran
with some whales with the whale or the
two pandas or something god I know my
and oh my gosh it's the feds Humpty pugs
like tons and tons of puppy bug there's
so many question and you have to get him
to sneak him across the border you know
we will never know and I don't want to
know that's the great part of the humor
but yeah I'm just like what I mean that
that's like that's a new one for the
survey oh no clue the the serial realm
um but yeah I thought it was a I kind of
questioned a little bit the even though
they say morality is relative at the end
I do surprisingly kind of question the
morality a little bit cuz it's like the
moral is like yeah just you can't get
what you want
beat the shit out of people to get it
I'm kinda like I okay most people I
watch this are pretty smart and you know
Islam I kids have good sense of humor
and stuff but it was kind of like to be
through I don't know long fur
yes that is true um a
yeah they were kind of being dicked
around is no you know that's a wine to
be known around here she was being made
to feel like an inferior awful person
you're right they were even on the
fucking unicorn and even the ornaments
admit we're all just jerks and we won't
give you our hair and even for those
kinds yeah like yeah they're you know
we're really obnoxious and annoying and
frustrating and stuff you know that's
just kind of when there was one nice boy
who should just be who we are angry
angry with yeah no sigh sixteen 1d again
oh yeah I've seen in a while yeah I
would like to see maybe a what it's
weird to say it's like I would like to
see a little bit more I always feel like
there's like more comedy that can be
done with her especially like getting
ready to like kick the crap out of the
unicorns and stuff like that bills more
like okay that's badass so we've liked a
little bit more comedy but it's like it
was kind of nice to see her again just
be like she was kind of left out in the
loop in his hos games I want to play
every single one of those games well and
I'm wondering if that yeah that was more
panel shoot selling Stalin chem yeah
absolutely yeah the the Jumanji game
that they had out what's the worst that
could happen which I'm betting that's
gonna be another episode because that
was really well designed it's way too
good an idea although I guess they'd
probably be pretty similar to the
dungeons of dragons one probably um but
yeah I can see that being an episode I
can see it being pretty fun in the final
game kid the unicorns colorful ass
oh yeah thank you decor was funny um but
uh yeah I follows a lot of fun and I
thought weird out of nowhere food fight
reference the just showing all the good
deeds are doing and then just suddenly
it shows them like in a card that's
clearly a satire of the food fight
poster I di I don't know why just
referencing that they saw a food fight I
guess but uh yeah it was funny to see um
and yeah I'm trying to think what else
interesting that that ciphered can get
himself in for it's Miami says he has a
metal plate there but it's kind of like
it's just knowing I don't get if if the
metal plate is supposed to do that how
did dipper read his mind with the
machine
good point
maybe the machine I just doesn't my
little fight I was just watching that I
was like wait a second I thought that
was the whole point of the metal plate
but this machine that could apparently
jalaja will be like you know wait wait
I'm sure they have a plan and they like
the writers are seeing in the forums oh
crap we forgot about that
oh right something around it there's
gotta be some way around it oh it turns
out who cares it's just a cartoon show
move on this is shit
um but ya know I felt was really funny
if I along good laughs that unicorns
amazing um should I show up at my
unicorn button oh go ahead yes my my
wife got me this and she put it up this
is a real thing it just cracked me up
this is the Easter unica but and the my
thing is it actually has a voice exactly
like the unicorn we just saw on grace
the wind until your HUD content it's
amazing
it says four magical things never stop
believing miracles everywhere all right
forget to my favorite one hey whole name
is your horn only when you have to and
my absolute favorite one good
oh that rainbow to your dreams no they
were wait there's one more if I won
ethical entities on the happy tops of
sunlit clouds that's it that laughs
kills me cuz that sounds like the
pedophile from Family Guy
maybe the unicorn it is but no we don't
know that much about we found out their
dicks so that very well could be but we
make nice buttons the thumbs yes so um
that's about anything else thank I think
we're done I Ingrid down here now give
you some treasure if you get the fuck
out nothing else to say but where's the
wind until your heart's content